Wie ist es?
Leben wir, um arbeiten zu können,
oder arbeiten wir,
um leben zu können?
Auf diese Frage suche ich
in dieser Sendung Antworten.
Macht Arbeit glücklich?
Ich glaube, dass ich es schaffe.
Das ist so. Das glaube ich.
Es gibt durchaus Situationen,
in denen mir alles zu viel wird.
Man kommt nicht einmal
zum Trinken oder zum Essen.
Ich sehe es eher als Hobby.
Dann arbeiten, wenn es etwas bringt.
Man merkt, dass wir Teamplayer.
Wir müssen
mit den Leuten zusammenarbeiten.
Ich liebe es,
dass ich meinen Tag gestalten kann,
dass ich meine eigene Chefin bin.
Menschen brauchen auch immer
eine gewisse Wertschätzung.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
* Beschwingte Klänge *
Ich bin im Café Tante in Basel.
Das ist Rahel, die Geschäftsführerin.
Rahel,
macht dich deine Arbeit glücklich?
Sie macht mich sehr glücklich, ja.
Ich liebe das Gastgeberische
und die Leute des Quartiers,
die hierherkommen, für die
es mehr als nur ein Café ist.
Eigentlich
geht es jetzt um diesen Kaffee,
der hier serviert wird.
Das ist der Kaffee,
den das Unternehmerpaar Tuil
aus Äthiopien
hier in der Schweiz vertreibt.
Die Tuils haben ein sehr spezielles
Verhältnis zur Arbeit.
Sie sagen nämlich: "15 Std. arbeiten
pro Woche muss genug sein."
Die Wohnung von Michael und Marie
Tuil und ihren beiden Kindern -
Geschäftssitz
ihrer Firma Direct Coffee.
Oh.
- Nein, da.
Okay.
Ihre Dreizimmerwohnung ist Kinder-
zimmer, Büro, Sitzungszimmer ...
... Kaffeelager ...
- Alles zusammen.
Bei uns ist es so:
Das ist das Wohnzimmer mit Küche.
Dann haben wir ein Ruhezimmer
und ein Spielzimmer.
Genau, so ist es definiert.
- Dies ist auch das Büro.
Ja, ja, das ist unser Büro.
Ich arbeite immer am Esstisch.
Michael arbeitet sozusagen
im Bücherregal.
Weil er gerne stehend arbeitet.
- Genau.
* Marie summt eine Melodie. *
Arbeit und Freizeit -
der Alltag der Tuils
kennt diese Unterscheidung kaum.
Ihre Frau singt ein Wiegenlied
und Sie arbeiten.
Ist das Alltag bei Ihnen?
Wir können unseren Alltag
so gestalten,
dass wir beide
viel Zeit mit den Kindern haben,
Marie und ich.
Dann können wir
sehr konzentriert arbeiten,
wenn die Kinder schlafen,
sie mit anderen Kindern
draussen sind oder so.
Das funktioniert sehr gut im Alltag.
Schläft.
Das Unternehmerehepaar
arbeitet sehr viel weniger
als in seinem früheren Leben als
Journalistin und Unternehmensberater.
Und sie seien trotzdem produktiver
als damals.
Was wir damit meinen, ist,
dass wir richtig konzentriert
am Computer arbeiten können.
Das ist auf ca. 15 Std. begrenzt.
Was aber natürlich
ganz viel Arbeit ist:
Wenn ich z.B. die Texte
für die Webseite schreibe.
Da muss ich überlegen,
was da reinkommt.
Das kann ich
vor dem Computer machen.
Früher hätte ich das so gemacht.
Jetzt aber überlege ich mir,
wie ich die Seite machen will ...
... und was ich ungefähr
drin haben will.
Wenn ich merke,
dass nichts mehr kommt,
gehe ich mit den Kindern spazieren.
Das ist dann Zeit,
die ich als Kinderzeit,
oder wenn ich koche als Kochzeit,
oder wenn ich schwimmen gehe,
als meine Zeit nehme bzw. "zähle".
Die gehört dann nicht zu den 15 Std.
Aber ich sehe die Zeit als sehr
wichtig an, um Ideen zu generieren.
Alors, tac.
Tac, tac.
Die Familie minimiert ihre Auslagen.
Mietkosten für Büroräume entfallen.
Als wir das Unternehmen
gegründet haben,
haben wir als Erstes
unsere Lebenskosten reduziert.
Früher haben wir mehr ausgegeben.
Wir haben gesehen,
dass wir glücklicher sind.
Es fehlt uns nicht mehr,
teurere Dinge zu kaufen oder ...
Oder einfach viele Sachen.
Genau, viele Sachen.
Das fehlt uns nicht.
Wir sind glücklicher mit weniger.
Das gibt uns eine Befreiung,
eine Kraft
und auch eine Zuversicht
und ein Vertrauen in die Zukunft.
Wir sind superglücklich mit dem,
was wir haben.
Wir leben nicht von Geld,
das wir gar nicht haben.
Das ist noch heiss.
Ist das heiss?
Ich glaube, alles ist heiss -
ausser Tomaten und Gurken.
Im kleinen Kellerabteil
des Mehrfamilienhauses in Basel
verpackt Marie Tuil Kundengeschenke.
Hier ist die Ökonomin und
Journalistin ihre eigene Chefin.
Bei "Die Zeit" oder der "Süddeut-
schen" zu arbeiten, war ein Traum.
Es ist ein guter Name
und viele Leute lesen deine Artikel.
Aber ich habe gemerkt,
dass der Arbeitsalltag wichtig ist.
Und der war mir ...
... zu strukturiert.
Ich sass zu viel im Büro.
Ich merkte,
dass das für mich nicht passt.
Aber damals war das kein bewusstes
"Ich muss weg von Hierarchien".
Es war einfach das Gefühl, dass wir
etwas Eigenes gründen wollten.
Ihr zweites unternehmerisches Stand-
bein sind Solarpanels für den Balkon.
Arbeit, die beide glücklich macht.
Ich habe es mitgebracht.
- Ja.
Okay.
Für mich sind es drei Dinge:
Das Erste ist der Sinn.
Wenn du nach einem Jahr auf das
zurückschaust, was du gemacht hast,
weisst du,
warum du das gemacht hast.
Das Zweite ist,
dass man im Flow arbeiten kann.
Dass man dann arbeiten kann,
wenn man einen guten Moment hat.
Diese Flexibilität.
Und das Dritte ist,
dass man immer mehr dazulernt.
# Aux Champs-Elysées.
# Baram-baram-bam.
- Voilà!
So, hier sind wird mit den Tuils.
Wenn ich mir das so ansehe ...
... erübrigt sich eigentlich die
Frage, ob euch das glücklich macht.
Es sieht wie das perfekte Idyll aus.
Ist es das?
- Ich würde sagen Ja.
Ja, tatsächlich.
Wir sind sehr zufrieden.
Wir leben das Leben jeden Tag so,
wie wir uns das vorstellen.
Wir lieben, was wir tun,
wir wissen, warum wir es tun
und wir haben viel Zeit
für andere Dinge,
die uns sehr wichtig sind:
für uns beide, die Familie,
die Kinder - und das ist wunderbar.
Wir hatten früher auch tolle Jobs.
Die waren sehr interessant.
Aber jetzt machen wir genau das,
was wir für wichtig erachten
und genau so,
wie wir es für richtig erachten.
Wir sind reich an Zeit,
reich an Leben
und reich an Glück.
Und das ist das,
was uns wichtig ist.
Es ist sehr spannend, dass ihr beide
sagt, ihr hättet das Glück gefunden.
Es gab einen Artikel
im "Tagesanzeiger" über euch.
Und dort merkte man, dass euer Glück
viele Leute extrem aufregt.
Das hat mich verwundert.
In der Kommentarspalte
ging es richtig zur Sache.
Es war schon fast ein Shitstorm.
Man las dort u.a. von Schmarotzertum,
Steueroptimierung,
von der Ungerechtigkeit,
dass ihr absichtlich wenig arbeitet
und trotzdem Krankenkassen-
verbilligungen erhaltet usw.
Eigentlich war der Tenor, dass ihr
ein tolles Leben für euch lebt,
aber eigentlich
auf dem Buckel der Gesellschaft.
Ist das so?
- Ne, ist es nicht.
Wir bezahlen mit unserem Unternehmen
mehr Steuern,
als wir Verbilligungen vom Staat
erhalten.
Und wir bezahlen auch gerne Steuern.
Es ist nicht so,
dass wir Steuern optimieren
und uns deswegen
wenig Lohn auszahlen.
Wir zahlen uns wenig Lohn aus,
weil wir unseren Konsum
runtergeschraubt haben.
Dann lassen wir lieber mehr
im Unternehmen, zahlen Gewinnsteuer
und investieren das wieder
in neue Unternehmen,
die dem Planeten
weiterhelfen können.
Wir sehen einfach,
dass wir für unseren Verbrauch -
wie ein Durchschnittsschweizer
lebt - drei Planeten brauchen.
Die haben wir nicht.
Deshalb möchten wir andere Leute
dazu inspirieren,
dass weniger Verbrauch
glücklicher macht.
Das ist die einzige Lösung,
die für die Zukunft verträglich ist.
Und sie ist wunderbar vereinbar
mit Glück,
toller Arbeits- und Familienzeit.
Das klingt sehr logisch.
Trotzdem
ist es das für viele Leute nicht.
Für viele Leute ist so
ein Lebensentwurf eine Provokation.
Conny Wunsch ist auch bei uns.
Sie ist Professorin für
Arbeitsmarktökonomie hier in Basel.
Ganz persönlich: Wenn Sie sich
diesen Lebensentwurf ansehen,
viel weniger konsumieren,
aber dafür viel weniger arbeiten:
Gefällt Ihnen das?
Das ist eine individuelle
Entscheidung und das ist okay so.
Überträgt man das
auf die ganze Gesellschaft
oder auf die Frage,
warum die Leute sich daran stören,
muss man bedenken, dass viele Leute
für ein sehr geringes Familienein-
kommen sehr viele Stunden arbeiten.
Wenn man ihnen sagt,
sie sollten 15 Std. arbeiten,
um mehr Zeit
für die Familie zu haben,
fragen die, wovon sie leben sollen.
Sie haben keine Stundenlöhne,
die garantieren,
dass sie von 15 Std. die Woche
leben können.
Die Frage ist:
Hat jeder das Privileg ...
... die Arbeit zu machen,
die genau diese Bedingungen erfüllt?
Das andere ist auch das Konzept
der Sozialversicherungssysteme,
was ja implizit mit "Schmarotzer"
und "nichts einzahlen" gemeint ist:
Wenn alle das machen, auch die,
die sich das leisten können,
haben wir das Problem,
dass zu wenig eingezahlt wird.
Es wird zu wenig
in die Systeme eingezahlt.
Und es gibt mehr Leute,
die Geld daraus erhalten.
Wie soll das tragfähig sein?
Irgendwo muss das Geld herkommen.
Ich weiss gar nicht,
ob das so viele Schweizerinnen
und Schweizer möchten.
Schaut man sich die Abstimmung zum
bedingungslosen Grundeinkommen an:
klar abgelehnt.
Sechste Ferienwoche: klar abgelehnt.
Wollen die Schweizerinnen
und Schweizer viel arbeiten?
Man sieht ganz klar,
dass es den Trend dazu gibt,
dass die Leute weniger arbeiten.
Arbeitsinhalte sind z.B.
viel wichtiger als die Bezahlung.
Sie sind auch zunehmend bereit,
auf Einkommen zu verzichten,
wenn sie dafür Teilzeit arbeiten
können und mehr Freizeit haben,
damit die Work-Life-Balance
besser stimmt.
Aber mein Eindruck ist, auch wenn
ich verschiedene Abstimmungen sehe,
dass die Schweizerinnen und Schwei-
zer sich durchaus bewusst sind,
woher
der Wohlstand des Landes kommt
und dass das eine
mit dem anderen zusammenhängt.
Da ist ein grosses Problem,
dass Wohlstand
in der Wirtschaftswissenschaft,
was wir beide auch studiert haben,
immer mit Wirtschat,
also dem BIP, dem Bruttoinland-
produkt, gleichgesetzt wird.
Das ist überhaupt nicht der Fall.
Wenn viele Menschen krank sind
und Gesundheitsleistungen
in Anspruch nehmen,
wächst die Wirtschaft.
Das ist gut für die Wirtschaft,
aber schlecht für die Gesellschaft.
Wenn wir Kriege haben
und Waffen herstellen,
wächst die Wirtschaft, aber es
ist nicht gut für die Gesellschaft.
Wie müsste man es denn messen?
Im Königreich Bhutan z.B.
gibt es das Bruttonationalglück.
Müsste es so eine Kennziffer geben?
- Ja, ganz genau. Ja.
Die Politik
sollte nicht das Wirtschaftswachstum
oder die Wirtschaftsleistung
maximieren,
sondern das Glück der Menschen.
Dann wäre so etwas,
dass viel mehr Leute
wahrscheinlich 50 % arbeiten
möchten, förderungswürdig.
Für das Glück.
Wir wollen aber niemanden
dazu zwingen oder drängen,
unser Beispiel nachzumachen.
Wir sehen aber,
dass es viele Menschen inspiriert.
Da wir wissen,
dass der Planet begrenzt ist ...
Für unsere Kinder sieht die Zukunft
im Moment wirklich düster aus.
Oder brennend, ich sage es mal so.
Es ist uns ein Anliegen,
die Menschen dazu zu inspirieren,
den Konsum
einfach mal zu hinterfragen.
Die Wirtschaft
muss für den Menschen da sein
und nicht der Mensch
für die Wirtschaft.
Man muss umdenken.
Haben wir zu hohe Ansprüche?
Muss Arbeit uns glücklich machen
bzw. kann sie das?
Ist unser Anspruch vielleicht falsch?
Ich arbeite, um meinen
Lebensunterhalt zu finanzieren.
Dann macht mich das
vielleicht nicht glücklich,
aber es ist
eine wirtschaftliche Notwendigkeit.
Für Teile der Bevölkerung
trifft das zu.
Und andere haben das Privileg,
das nicht zu müssen.
Sie können selber entscheiden,
wie viel sie konsumieren möchten
und wie sie ihre Arbeit gestalten.
Wollen wir das? Eine Gruppe, die das
nicht kann und eine, die es kann?
Aber wie viel man konsumiert,
kann jeder selbst entscheiden.
Aber auch,
was einen glücklich macht.
Klar.- Gewisse Leute
macht Konsum glücklich.
Sie können das anders definieren.
- Wissenschaftlich ...
Die Psychologen beschäftigen
sich seit Jahrzehnten damit,
und Konsum
macht nicht wirklich glücklich.
Ihr seid schon weit voraus.
Ich sehe von wirtschaftlicher Seite
noch zwei, drei, vier
grosse Fragezeichen.
Wir werden das nicht klären können.
Vielen Dank
für den Einblick in euer Leben.
Sicher ist eines: Marie
und Michael Tuil haben gefunden,
was wohl viele von uns suchen:
nämlich einen Beruf, der erfüllt
und der sinnhaft ist.
Sie sagen,
das stimme perfekt für sie.
Das ist so  d e r  Traumberuf.
Aber was ist das eigentlich?
Was macht einen Traumberuf aus?
Wir haben
auf den Strassen Aaraus nachgefragt.
Kondukteur bei der Rhätischen Bahn.
Ärztin.- Ärztin.
- Psychotherapeutin.
Eigentlich Friedhofsgärtner.
Wieso?- Weil mein dort seine Ruhe
hat und nicht gestört wird.
Ich habe meinen Traumjob:
Ich bin Hausarzt.
Das sagt eigentlich schon alles.
Mein Traumjob war der,
den ich hatte:
Ich habe Mechaniker gelernt
und wurde dann Betriebsmechaniker.
Das ist so vielseitig.
Mit dem Wissensstand
der heutigen Zeit
würde ich etwas
in der Flugzeugbranche machen.
Mein Traumjob wäre eigentlich,
Bibelhistorikerin zu werden.
Aber in der Schweiz gibt es
nicht so viele Möglichkeiten.
Da müsste man eher Richtung
Israel und Palästina gehen.
Pilot.
- Architekt.- Lokführer.
Ich habe keinen Traumjob.
Kindergärtnerin oder Primarlehrerin.
- Schauspieler.
Filme drehen.
- Sängerin.
Wenn man durch seine Arbeit
irgendwie das Gefühl hat,
dass man das Leben von anderen
Menschen besser machen kann.
Ein berühmter Zauberer zu werden.
Primarlehrerin.
- Sind Sie das?- Ja.
Schauspielerin.
Ich wollte das gerne machen, aber
ich habe die Chance nicht erhalten.
Schauspielerin
ist ein gutes Stichwort.
Das klingt schon
nach Traum und Glamour.
Eine junge Zürcherin hat alles
auf die Karte Schauspielerei gesetzt:
Sabrina Kern. Sie hat es
bis nach Hollywood geschafft.
Cut. Roll camera, roll sound.
Rolling.
* Bedrohliche Klänge *
No.
- Follow me. I'll show you out.
No, don't go! Don't go, no!
Come back! Come back!
* Düstere Musik *
Wie kommt eine junge Frau
aus der Schweiz auf die Idee,
dass sie nach L.A. will ...
... um eine Hollywood-Karriere
zu machen?
Wie ist das entstanden?
Eigentlich
entstand das aus der Idee,
dass ich Anwältin werden wollte.
Davon war ich immer voll überzeugt.
Bis ich irgendwann merkte,
dass ich das gar nicht wollte,
sondern dass ich lieber
eine vor der Kamera spielen wollte.
Sie werden wütend,
wenn ich nicht gehe.
Sonst werden sie wütend.
Auf dem Filmset
dreht sich alles um die Schweizerin.
Sie ist der Star.
Ihre erste Hauptrolle.
Der Thriller heisst "St. Agatha" und
hat ein Budget von rund 1,5 Mio. ¤.
You come out the door ...
Das ist Darren Bousman,
der Regisseur.
Er drehte drei Folgen
des Horrorfilmklassikers "Saw",
die Dutzende Millionen einspielten.
You walk and walk and then you stop.
- Yeah.
Der Amerikaner hat einen
hervorragenden Ruf in der Branche.
Für die 28-jährige Schweizerin ist
die Hauptrolle in seinem neusten Film
ein riesiger Karrieresprung.
* Bedrohliche Klänge *
Die Zürcherin
spielt eine schwangere Frau,
die in einem Kloster
gefangen gehalten wird.
* Bedrohliche Klänge *
Sabrina Kern absolvierte
die renommierte American Academy
of Dramatic Arts in Los Angeles.
Viele Hollywood-Stars
haben dort ihr Handwerk gelernt.
No! No!
Es ist aufregend,
jemanden zu entdecken.
Mit diesem Film will ich Sabrina
einem breiteren Publikum
präsentieren.
* Chillige Rockmusik *
Sabrina Kern lebt seit einem Jahr
mit ihrer zweiten Familie,
wie sie es nennt, in Los Angeles.
Alle vier
wohnen gemeinsam in einer WG.
Das sind ihr Freund Stee
und dessen Schwester Co,
bekannt als Indie-Pop-Duo ZiBBZ.
Cos Ehemann Yves ist Profigolfer.
Vier Schweizer,
die sich an diesem Samstagmorgen
einige Stunden Freizeit gönnen,
bevor sie wieder um einen guten Platz
im Scheinwerferlicht der Traumfabrik
kämpfen werden.
* Chillige Rockmusik *
Alle vier
arbeiten hart an ihren Karrieren.
Momentan ist Los Angeles
der Mittelpunkt ihres Universums.
Doch das kann sich schnell ändern.
Wenn wir Glück haben ...
... funktioniert es irgendwie,
dass wir am gleichen Ort arbeiten.
Ja, aber das ist
mit jedem Künstlerleben so:
Man muss nehmen, was kommt,
und dort sein, wo es kommt.- Genau.
Früher oder später
schlägt es ein oder nicht.
Aber man muss dorthin,
wo die Arbeit ist.
Darauf haben wir uns
auch eingestellt.- Genau.
Um möglichst günstig zu wohnen,
teilen sich die Freunde
ein kleines Haus.
Viel Privatsphäre bleibt da nicht,
zumal das Haus auch noch Übungsraum
und Tonstudio ist.
* Schlagzeug *
Ist gut?
Läufst du mir einfach
in die Aufnahme rein?
Tschau, bis nachher.
Nach unzähligen Hürden
hat sich Sabrina Kern
eines der heiss begehrten Künstler-
visa für Schauspieler ergattert.
* Sanftes Poplied:
"Hollywood" von Madonna *
# Everybody comes to Hollywood.
Der Nachteil dieses Visums:
Die Schweizerin darf ausschliesslich
in der Showbranche arbeiten.
Aber gerade da ist der Stellenmarkt
besonders umkämpft.
Hier fand sie ihren ersten Job.
Sie ist ihm bis heute treu geblieben.
Einmal pro Woche
arbeitet sie für eine Firma,
die Dinner in einer Originalflugzeug-
kabine der Airline Pan Am anbietet.
Sie ist als Schauspielerin angestellt
und gibt die Maître de Cabine.
Any other d... Really?
500 Fr. und mehr
bezahlen die Gäste für einen Abend
in einem stilechten Interieur
aus den 70er-Jahren.
Ihr Chef erkannte schnell,
dass die Tochter eines Wirtehepaars
noch ganz andere Qualitäten hat.
Okay, got it. Wait one second.
Deshalb
koordiniert die Schauspielerin
nebenbei auch noch den ganzen Ablauf
hinter den Kulissen.
I don't know if that'll work out.
Meine Eltern sagten immer,
es sei schwierig,
Restaurantmitarbeiter zu finden,
die so denken, als wäre es ihres,
als würde das Restaurant
ihnen gehören.
Man arbeitet anders, wenn man weiss,
dass das eigene Herz dahintersteckt.
Darum versuche ich, jeden Job -
egal welchen - so anzugehen ...
... als wäre es
mein passion project,
als hätte ich es
in die Welt gerufen.
Dann arbeitet man irgendwie anders.
Man gibt mehr.
You're kidding?
Wait, so we only have one?
Für diese hektische Schicht
verdient sie gerade einmal 150 Fr.
Und sie ist zufrieden. Auch das
ist eine Realität in Hollywood.
Cheers, mate. Cheers.
Sabrina Kern
besucht ihre Familie in Zürich.
Mutter Sissi und Vater Nicolas
betreiben mehrere Restaurants.
Eines der Lokale
führt Sabrinas Schwester Melanie.
Bevor sie sich
ins Hollywood-Abenteuer stürzte,
studierte Sabrina Kern
an der Universität Zürich
Kommunikation, Politik und BWL.
Die Chance, dass man in diesem
Geschäft reüssiert, ist minimal.
So viele Leute wollen das.
- Die ist absolut marginal.
Dessen sind wir uns bewusst.
- Das ist so.- Gut.
Aber mit viel Fleiss,
Ehrgeiz und Drive, was Sabrina hat,
glauben wir trotzdem dran,
dass sie es schaffen kann.
Hoffen muss man immer,
sonst sollte man das nicht machen.
Ja.
- Oder?
Man muss es versuchen.
Und sie versucht es.
Sie ist auf einem sehr guten Weg.
Wir freuen uns, wenn sie es schafft
und wir an eine Oscar-Verleihung
gehen können.
Das ist ...
- Das kommt als Nächstes.
"I'm gonna thank my mom and my dad"
- das muss kommen.
Das ist gesetzt.
Noch ist sie auch finanziell
immer wieder auf die Unterstützung
ihrer Eltern angewiesen.
Ist es wirklich nur möglich, wenn
die ganze Familie hinter einem steht,
rein finanziell,
um so etwas überhaupt zu versuchen?
Nein, nicht nur.
Es ginge auch sonst.
Aber dann
wäre es noch etwas schwieriger
und der Druck wäre grösser.
Es hilft.
- Es hilft sicher. Aber langsam ...
... kommen zum Glück
bessere Angebote
und ich hoffe,
ich brauche das nicht mehr lange.
Ich geniesse es, aber ...
... ich würde zehnmal lieber
ganz unabhängig sein können
und keine Unterstützung
mehr brauchen.
Aber ja ...
# Marching to the drums
of my own little lone band.
# I'm breathing life
into La La alone land.
Um sich auch als Sängerin
im Showbusiness zu empfehlen,
produziert Sabrina Kern
ihr erstes Musikvideo.
Das Lied hat sie mit Freund Stee und
einem Schauspielkollegen geschrieben.
Die Regie macht Darren Bousman,
der Regisseur des Horrorfilms.
Heute ist die 28-Jährige
seine Chefin.
So, the next shot
is with all four girls?- Yeah.
Okay.
# Watch Hollywood acknowledge me.
# Then probably
you'll call in your apology.
Sabrina Kerns Budget
für das Musikvideo
beträgt gerade einmal 2'000 Fr.
Deshalb hat sie Freunde und Bekannte
aus der Branche zusammengetrommelt,
die bereit sind,
auf ihre Gage zu verzichten.
Auch das ist Hollywood.
Ganz viele Menschen
wähnen sich kurz vor dem Durchbruch.
Für diesen Traum
opfern sie fast alles.
Feel her backing away from you -
show it in your face.
Start just fucking losing it.
Ich habe immer ...
Ich glaube, dass ich es schaffe.
Das ist so. Das glaube ich.
Und das macht, dass ich weitermache.
Die Tonnen hier stehen nicht irgendwo
in einem Hinterhof von Hollywood,
sondern in Zürich Witikon.
Sabrina Kern
ist zurück in der Schweiz.
Was sie hier macht,
finden wir jetzt raus.
# My little lone band.
# I'm breathing life
into La La alone land.
Wir nehmen die Socken ab.
Sie sieht wie das friedlichste Kind
aus, das man sich vorstellen kann.
Ihre Lieblingsbeschäftigung
ist dramatic sleeping.
Dramatic sleeping?
- (Beide) Dramatic sleeping.
In dramatischen Positionen.
- Ja.
Mit beiden Armen oben.
- Schau! Du siehst es.
Eine klassische Schauspielerin.
Die grösste Veränderung
haben wir schon gesehen.
Als wir dich verlassen haben, hast du
in dem grossen Film mitgespielt
und das war ein Moment,
als alles möglich war.
Was ist danach passiert?
Es war wirklich super.
Wir konnten an Festivals
und alle Filmpremieren gehen.
Das zog sich noch
über ein bis eineinhalb Jahre hin.
Das war eine tolle
und spannende Zeit.
Dann hatte ich die Möglichkeit,
für Erich Vock ein Casting
für die "Niederdorfoper" zu machen -
in Zürich.
Darum ... Es ist nicht so, als
hätten wir nie darüber gesprochen,
mal in die Schweiz zurückzukommen.
Das war immer ein Thema.
Aber ich wollte
einen wichtigen Grund dafür.
Ich wollte nicht zurückkommen,
ohne dass mich etwas zurückholt.
Wie glamourös ist das Leben in Holly-
wood tatsächlich, wenn man es hat?
Sehr oft gar nicht glamourös.
Es ist ...
Wie wir gelebt haben,
hat es gar keinen Glamour.
Im Gegenteil: Wir lebten zu sechst
in einem Haus mit einem Badezimmer.
Ich und Co mit vier Männern.
Das ist nicht immer lustig.
Ich fand es lustig.
* Lachen *
Nein, es ist nicht ohne.
Es war alles, was wir brauchten.
Wenn du dann aber an einem Filmset
bist und die Hauptrolle hast -
für diese drei bis sechs Wochen
fühlt es sich plötzlich
sehr glamourös an.
Alle kümmern sich um einen
und man ist plötzlich ganz wichtig.
Aber kaum ist der Film fertig ...
Es geht von mega ...
Man hat das Gefühl ...
... man sei die wichtigste Person
der Welt für ein paar Wochen
und dann interessiert sich
wieder niemand für einen.
Man muss lernen, mit den Hochs
und Tiefs umzugehen.- Mega.
Bei dir mit Eurovision auch.
- Ja, ja.
Eurovision Vollgas, crazy,
und am nächsten Tag ist man zu Hause
und fragt sich,
wo man als Nächstes spielt.
Man hat immer ...
Ja.
- Das ist spannend.
Ich gehe ja der Frage nach,
was an der Arbeit glücklich macht.
Bei der Schauspielerei
und mit der Musik
denkt man immer,
man könne erst glücklich sein,
wenn du ganz oben angekommen bist.
- Ja.
Das schaffen aber die wenigsten.
Genau.
- Warum macht man das trotzdem?
Für mich war es immer das
Kreativsein, das mich geflasht hat.
Nicht unbedingt
die einzelnen Erfolge.
Klar, sind die schön, und es
braucht sie auch, um weiterzumachen,
aber die Kreation macht mich happy.
So blöd es klingt:
Der Weg ist auch das Ziel.
Dass man überhaupt davon leben kann,
egal, auf welchem ...
... Level.
Bei mir ist es etwas anders.
Ich finde z.B. ...
An all die Castings zu gehen
macht mich eher nicht glücklich.
Also im Sinne von ...
Ich bin mega nervös,
wenn ich an ein Casting gehe.
Man braucht so eine dicke Haut.
Bei 100 Auditions
hörst du 99-mal ein Nein.
Man braucht wirklich
eine dicke Haut dafür,
um das zu ertragen ...
- Es macht kaputt.
... dass man so oft ein Nein hört.
Wie muss ich mir
dieses Nein vorstellen?
Meistens
hört man einfach nichts mehr
und fragt sich
noch Monate später ...- Warum?
... ob man schlecht war
oder vielleicht noch was hört.
Man wartet auf etwas,
das nicht kommt.
Also, das Nein
ist quasi einfach nichts zu hören.
Ja.
- Funkstille.
Was ist der Preis, den man zahlt,
wenn man auf so einen Job setzt?
Von der Sicherheit,
die die Schweizer gerne haben ...
... muss man sich verabschieden.
Die Sicherheit, dass man nächsten
Monat so und so viel verdient,
hat man nie.
Und ...
... damit
muss man sich sicher abfinden.
Man weiss einfach nicht,
was in der Zukunft ist.
Es kann sein, dass man plötzlich
einen Film bucht
und dann erhältst du auf einmal
einen guten Lohn.
Aber wenn du Pech hast,
muss das dann ein Jahr reichen,
weil man danach nichts mehr hat.
Während Corona
wurde es für sehr viele,
die in einem ähnlichen Bereich
tätig sind, wirklich existenziell.
Das hier: Könnt ihr das bezahlen
oder unterstützen euch deine Eltern?
Wie macht ihr das?
- Wir haben Unterstützung.
Das ist klar so.
Aber wir hatten im Corona-Jahr
beide Glück:
Wir konnten trotzdem
immer weiterarbeiten.
Ich nicht nur auf dem Beruf,
den ich möchte.
Ich konnte nicht
auf der Bühne stehen,
aber ich unterrichte Schauspiel
und konnte damit gut weiterleben.
Auch online. Ich habe viel
über Zoom unterrichtet.
Und Yoga.
- Yoga auch.
Und ich darf immer noch
im Restaurant arbeiten.
So unterstützen mich meine Eltern.
Das machst du auch?
- Ja, ja.
Alles Gute für euch
und vielen Dank für das Interview.
Jetzt haben wir zwei gesehen,
die für das brennen, was sie machen.
Man muss sich fragen, was Jobs wären,
die man gar nicht machen würde.
Was wären Albtraumjobs?
Ein Albtraumjob wäre aktuell
vermutlich etwas in der Pflege.
Oder so ein Fliessbandjob, bei dem
man tagtäglich dasselbe macht,
der schlecht bezahlt
und stressig ist, ohne Anerkennung.
Zahnarzt.
- Baustelle.
Kaminfeger - wegen des Outfits.
In einer Bank.
Da war ich früher mal.
Metzger.
- In einem Büro arbeiten.
Ich glaube, auf dem Bau
wäre für mich schwierig.
Abfall einsammeln oder so.
Es ist ein wichtiger Job, aber ich
könnte mir das nicht vorstellen.
Müllabfuhr würde ich auch machen.
Ich bin froh, arbeiten zu können.
An einem Förderband zu stehen.
- Ärztin.
Excel-Tabellen im Büro ausfüllen
und keinen Kundenkontakt zu haben.
Polizist.
- Mechaniker.
Füsse zu massieren.
- Rumzusitzen und nichts zu machen.
Oh ...
Das ist nicht schwierig:
etwas in der Pflege, denke ich.
Ist der Mensch überhaupt
für die Arbeit geschaffen?
Oder wäre es uns ohne Arbeit wohler?
Diese Frage stelle ich der "Stern-
stunde"-Moderatorin Barbara Bleisch.
Barbara Bleisch, als Philosophin ...
Es nimmt mich wunder, ob die Frage
"Macht Arbeit glücklich?" etwas ist,
das wir uns in der Neuzeit fragen,
oder ist das eine Frage,
die schon früher beschäftigt hat?
In dieser Art und Weise würde ich
sagen, ist es eine neuere Frage.
Es hat die Philosophen und
Philosophinnen immer interessiert,
wie man ein gutes Gleichgewicht
zwischen Arbeit und Musse hinkriegt.
Aber die Idee der Arbeit war immer,
dass es halt sein muss
und es gut ist,
wenn man es weniger machen kann.
Aber dass die Arbeit
glücklich machen soll,
ist eine neuere Idee.
- Es ist interessant:
Die Frage bedeutet auch schon fast,
dass Arbeit glücklich machen sollte.
Erwarten wir einfach zu viel?
Jein.
Ich würde das umdrehen und sagen,
dass wir erwarten können, dass
die Arbeit nicht unglücklich macht.
Weltweit gesehen, wäre das schon
ein riesiger Gewinn und Fortschritt.
Es gibt viele Arbeitsverhältnisse,
die ausbeuterisch sind
und in denen Menschen
in ihrer Würde verletzt werden,
wo Leute wirklich leiden
und ungesunde und gefährliche
Arbeitsbedingungen vorherrschen.
Der Anspruch, dass Arbeit
mind. nicht unglücklich macht,
ist ein absolut gerechtfertigter.
- Das ist nicht übertrieben.- Nein.
Die Kehrseite allerdings ist -
darauf willst du wohl hinaus -,
dass man zu viel
von der Arbeit erwartet.
Man kann fast sagen,
dass es eine Idee des Workism gibt.
Also diese Idee, dass die Arbeit
einen so ausfüllen soll,
dass sie zu unserer Identität wird.
Das gefällt natürlich
dem Arbeitgeber.
Arbeitnehmende, die sich
über ihre Arbeit definieren,
sind natürlich sehr leistungsfähig
und setzen sich enorm ein.
* Ruhige Musik *
Es ist auch spannend,
was wir unter Arbeit verstehen.
Im Vorfeld der Sendung merkte ich,
dass wir immer
von Lohnarbeit sprechen.
Ist das ein Zufall?
- Das ist ein wichtiger Aspekt.
Sehr viel Arbeit,
das ganze sog. Care Work -
Hausarbeit, Familienarbeit,
Pflege von Tieren, von
kranken Menschen, von Angehörigen,
von älteren Personen,
von Kindern usw. -
diesen ganzen Bereich rechnen wir
oft nicht zur Arbeit dazu,
obwohl man jetzt
von Care Work spricht,
weil diese Arbeit
nicht entlohnt wird.
Wir haben die Tendenz,
nur das als Arbeit zu bezeichnen,
was einen Lohn einbringt.
Das ist eine Verkürzung.
Man kann fragen, was es bringt,
wenn wir die ganze Care-Arbeit
als Arbeit bezeichnen
oder sie sogar bezahlen.
Es würde eine Aufwertung des ganzen
Sektors bringen.- Wertschätzung.
Eine Form von Wertschätzung
und Anerkennung.
Es gibt die schöne Geschichte
der drei Steinmetze:
Drei Steinmetze treffen sich.
Der erste sagt: "Ich behaue Stein."
Der zweite sagt:
"Ich arbeite und verdiene Lohn."
Und der dritte sagt: "Ich trage
zum Bau der Kathedrale bei."
Welcher ist wohl der glücklichste?
Wahrscheinlich der dritte,
weil er das Gefühl hat, etwas zu
einem grossen Ganzen beizutragen.
* Sanfte Klänge *
Wenn jemand
zum grossen Ganzen beiträgt,
sind das sicher Pflegekräfte.
Aber viele von ihnen sind im Moment
nicht besonders glücklich,
z.B. hier im Zürcher Kinderspital.
Noch ist es ruhig.
Die Spätschicht hat erst begonnen.
Hallo, da ist Luca vom Notfall.
Ich habe ein Röntgen angemeldet.
Das ist Anek.
Knapp 9 Std. dauert eine Schicht,
mit kurzen Pausen dazwischen.
Ich arbeite eigentlich
seit Mittwoch.
Heute habe ich Spätdienst.
D.h.,
jeden Tag von 14.15 Uhr bis 23 Uhr.
Morgen und übermorgen
habe ich noch Nachtwache.
D.h., von abends um 22.30 Uhr
bis morgens um 7.15 Uhr.
Dann hatte ich eigentlich
sieben Dienste am Stück.
Sie hatte so einen leeren Blick
ins Nichts.
Auf einem Kindernotfall zu arbeiten
ist wie Hochleistungssport:
extrem anspruchsvoll
bei höchster Konzentration.
Umso wichtiger, dass sich Ruhe-
und Arbeitszeiten die Waage halten.
Doch im Alltag eines Kindernotfalls
häufig gar nicht machbar.
Man hat nicht nur das,
für was man eingeplant ist.
Man muss immer wieder einspringen.
Man erhält eine SMS,
dass jemand fehle
und ob jemand einspringen könne.
Wenn man zu Hause ist, hat man fast
ein schlechtes Gewissen,
wenn man sich dann nicht meldet.
- Wir haben einen Chat.
Heute um 12 Uhr kam etwas.
Dann weiss man,
dass man zur Arbeit kommt
und fragt sich,
wer zum Spätdienst kommen könnte.
Man denkt:
"Mist, ich arbeite schon."
"Wahrscheinlich
sind wir zu wenig Leute."
"Es meldet sich
wahrscheinlich niemand."
Und wenn man nicht arbeitet,
überlegt man, ob man anrufen soll.
Ich arbeite 40 %.
Ich könnte oft kommen.
Aber es gibt ja einen Grund dafür,
warum man 40 oder 60 % arbeitet.
Jeden Monat
ist man zwei-, dreimal mehr hier.
Und man kann es nie kompensieren.
Irgendwann hängt das an.
Und dann das schlechte Gewissen:
"Ich muss ja fast gehen.
Die Kollegen stecken in der Klemme."
Noch besser ist der Frühdienst.
Da bist du zu zweit oder dritt.
Man steht um 5 Uhr auf und sieht,
dass ein Frühdienst kommen soll.
Das Erbrechen
beginnt meist in der Nacht.
Dann weiss man, dass man
wohl alleine hier sein wird.
Es geht immer irgendwie.
Aber im Chat
kommt einfach täglich eine Nachricht
zum Einspringen
für mehrere Schichten.
Die Pflegefachfrauen und -männer
sind im Kindernotfall die Ersten,
die das kranke Kind sehen
und reagieren müssen.
Die Verantwortung ist hoch.
Hoi.
Okay. Er muss sicher inhalieren.
Er atmet ...
... bronchitismässig.
- Ja.
Trinkt und isst er?
Etwas weniger, aber er macht es.
Okay.
Der Notfall füllt sich.
Die Betten sind alle belegt.
Die Pflegefachleute
betreuen mehrere Kinder gleichzeitig.
Ich muss schnell
ein Antibiotikum richten.
Ich muss mich kurz konzentrieren.
Mara, ich gebe deinem Kind
in der Eins noch Fenta.
Wer ist in der Eins?
Ich habe keinen Überblick mehr.
Der vom Baum.
- Den habe ich noch nicht gesehen.
Das ist schon gut.
- Okay.
Ich betreue meine Seite hier hinten
und arbeite die Verordnungen ab.
Es kamen gerade viele gleichzeitig.
Da muss man
wegen der Antibiotika usw. schauen.
Ich richte jetzt dann einen,
der nicht so fit ist.
Und ich habe momentan
die Schichtleitung,
weil die Schichtleitung gerade isst.
D.h., ich bin verantwortlich für das
Telefon, das immer wieder klingelt.
Wenn wieder ein Kind reinkommt,
würde man mich anpiepsen
und dann bräuchte ich ein Zimmer,
in das wir reinkönnen.
Genau.
Sie müssen sehr viel denken,
verantworten, handeln und machen.
Ja.
Im Schnitt kommen täglich
120 Kinder auf den Notfall.
Das sind 45'000 im Jahr.
* Weinen *
Bei klein Julius
ist mittlerweile klar:
Er hat eine schwere,
akute Bronchitis.
* Weinen *
Fertig, fertig, fertig.
Wenn etwas ist ...
... einfach den roten Knopf drücken.
Die Arbeitsbelastung
wird immer grösser
bei praktisch gleichem
Personalbestand.
Das kann langfristig nicht aufgehen.
Von der Pflege her: Wenn
genügend Leute auf der Schicht sind,
können wir sehr umfassend pflegen.
Es gibt aber Momente,
in denen wir gefährlich pflegen.
Da geht es nur noch darum,
ob das Kind atmet oder nicht.
Wir können nicht mehr
auf die Eltern achten,
wir können das Kind
nur noch knapp überwachen.
Das ist unbefriedigend.
Das ist das, was uns Mühe macht,
weil wir einfach gefährlich pflegen.
Man geht nach der Schicht nach Hause
und denkt:
"Gott sei Dank
ist heute nichts passiert."
So zu arbeiten
ist nicht mehr so schön.
Sibylle Heldstab vom Kinderspital
Zürich, die wir gesehen haben,
ist bei mir.
Mir fuhr der Film ein.
Ich hätte nicht gedacht,
dass die Situation so krass ist.
Haben wir einfach
die Unzufriedenen gesehen
oder geht es
mehr oder weniger allen so?
Zufrieden oder unzufrieden
ist sehr situationsbedingt.
Grundsätzlich
ist es einer der schönsten Berufe,
sonst wäre ich nicht
seit 30 Jahren im Beruf.
Ich arbeite Teilzeit, 50 %.
Das ist ein grosses Glück.
Ich möchte nicht mehr arbeiten.
- Warum?
Es zehrt an der Substanz.
Wir haben häufig wenig Leute,
wir rennen oft
und werden nicht gross unterstützt.
Wir sind oft am Limit.
Das macht müde.
Nach einem Tag auf den Beinen,
am Rumrennen ...
Häufig ist es auch sehr emotional.
Wir haben
viele verschiedene Krankheitsbilder.
Was müsste sich ändern?
Die ganze Einstellung -
letztlich auch von der Politik.
Werdet ihr zu wenig wertgeschätzt?
Mündlich
werden wir sehr wertgeschätzt.
Man klatscht für uns und in
Deutschland gab es sogar Lavendel.
In der Schweiz hört man oft,
dass es ein wichtiger Beruf sei,
das Beste, was man machen kann.
"Toll, haben wir euch!"
Das stimmt alles,
davon leben wir auch.
Aber grundsätzlich
sind die Bedingungen schon hart.
Es wird Personal gekürzt,
Funktionen werden gestrichen ...
Man könnte uns viel abnehmen.
Alle Anrufe, alles Schriftliche ...
Wir haben ein extrem breites Feld
an Aufgaben,
die gar nicht unsere Aufgaben wären.
Könnten wir
unser Kerngeschäft machen,
wäre es tatsächlich
viel entspannter.
Hier können wir unseren
zweiten Gesprächspartner reinbringen:
Stephan Sigrist,
Leiter des Think Tanks W.I.R.E.
Ihr beschäftigt euch
mit solchen Zukunftsfragen.
Wohin geht die Gesellschaft?
Wie entwickelt sich die Arbeit?
Gibt es Entwicklungen,
die in diese Richtung gehen,
von der Sibylle Heldstab
gesprochen hat?
Ja, ganz klar.
Auf der technologischen Seite sieht
man das Stichwort Digitalisierung,
das viel diskutiert wurde.
Es wird momentan viel verändert,
gerade im Umfeld der Spitäler.
Eine Idee bzw. Vision
ist tatsächlich,
dass man den Leuten
einfache, repetitive Aufgaben -
genau diese Aufgaben,
die sehr viel Zeit fressen -
abnehmen kann, damit sie sich
um das kümmern können,
wo die Wertschätzung stattfindet,
dort, wo der Mensch
nicht durch Maschinen ersetzbar ist.
Es gibt Hoffnung,
aber auch viele kritische Elemente,
die man beachten muss.
- Was sind die kritischen Elemente?
Man hört z.B. immer wieder
von Pflegerobotern.
Es gibt eine ganze Bandbreite.
Es gibt Roboter, die einem älteren
Patienten beim Aufstehen helfen.
Dann geht es natürlich weiter
und wir kommen
zu schwierigeren, ethischen Fällen.
Es gibt diese Streichelroboter,
die in Japan verbreitet sind.
Für Demenzkranke.
- Genau.
Das sind süsse Seehunde,
die sich ein wenig bewegen.
Da kann man sagen,
es gehe überhaupt nicht,
dass man einen Menschen
mit einer Maschine koppelt.
Allerdings zeigen klinische Studien,
dass es den Menschen,
die die Realität
nicht immer mehr ganz wahrnehmen,
damit körperlich besser geht.
Da kommen wir
an einen schwierigen Punkt:
Man muss als Gesellschaft entschei-
den, ob man das grundsätzlich will.
Oder kommen wir an einen Punkt,
wo man wie
bei einer Patientenverfügung sagt:
"Wenn ich irgendwann
nicht mehr ganz hier bin
und es tut mir gut, den Roboter
zu streicheln, lasse ich das zu."
Ist die Frage
"Macht Arbeit glücklich?"
auch der Ausdruck
eines Luxusproblems?
Ein First-World-Problem?
Ein bisschen schon.
Für viele Menschen
ist es schon ein riesiges Glück,
wenn sie überhaupt arbeiten können,
wenn sie eine Lohnarbeit haben,
ihre Existenzgrundlage sichern,
ihre Familien durchbringen,
die Schulgelder und Schuluniformen
der Kinder bezahlen können usw.
Dessen müssen wir uns bewusst sein.
Gleichzeitig habe ich ein Unbehagen,
wenn man
von First-World-Problems spricht
und sagt, es sei ein Luxusproblem,
man solle sich beruhigen.
Wir leben in dieser Gesellschaft
und jede Gesellschaft
bringt ihre eigenen Zwänge, Mecha-
nismen und Schwierigkeiten hervor.
Wenn man schaut, wie viele Menschen
hier ein Burn-out haben
oder auch sog. Bullshit-Jobs
machen müssen,
wie David Graeber das nennt ...
- Die sinnentleerten.
Sinnentleerte, bürokratische Arbeit,
mit der sie sich
nicht identifizieren können.
Sie haben nicht das Gefühl,
es mache einen Unterschied,
ob jemand die Arbeit macht
oder nicht.
Das sind Probleme, die wir
auch unbedingt ernst nehmen müssen.
Wir haben schon viel
über die Frage gehört,
wann uns Arbeit glücklich macht.
Sieht man sich Studien an,
heisst es u.a.,
dass uns Arbeit dann guttut,
wenn sie für uns Sinn macht,
wenn wir Verantwortung
übernehmen können
und eine gewisse Zukunftsperspektive
haben.
Bei anderen Studien
wird mehr Wert darauf gelegt,
dass es eigentlich schon reicht,
in einem guten Team zu arbeiten,
einen fairen Lohn und nette Arbeits-
kolleginnen und -kollegen zu haben.
Sicher ist eines:
Arbeit macht dann unglücklich,
wenn man sie eben nicht mehr hat.
* Staubsauger *
Andreas Knuchel, 59 Jahre alt,
arbeitslos seit drei Jahren.
Er ist Ingenieur Elektrotechnik
mit einem Nachdiplomstudium
als Betriebswirtschafter.
Er hat jahrzehntelang
in Führungspositionen gearbeitet,
mehrheitlich im Ausland -
bis er entlassen wurde.
Es gibt bessere Tage
und es gibt weniger gute Tage.
Gott sei Dank sind die weniger guten
nicht so häufig.
Aber es gibt sie.
Es ist auch heute noch so,
dass ich mich immer noch frage,
was ich falsch gemacht habe,
damit es mich getroffen hat.
Was hätte ich anders machen können?
Hätte ich merken sollen,
dass es in diese Richtung geht?
Solche Tage kommen.
Dagegen kann man sich nicht wehren.
Man muss damit umgehen können.
Darum ist es eben wichtig,
dass man ...
... an der Struktur des Tages
festhält.
Dass man nicht einfach sagt:
"Ich habe ja nichts mehr zu tun,
ich schlafe bis 11 oder 12 Uhr."
Das wäre komplett falsch.
Man muss eine Struktur beibehalten -
für den Körper und für sich selbst.
Das ist ein Freund,
der jeweils zu Besuch kommt.
Sali.
In seinem Haus in Bellach
ist Andreas Knuchel selten allein.
Er hat zwei erwachsene Kinder.
Genau, sie sollte hier drin sein.
Das wird schwierig.
Aber es ist Cup,
da ist alles möglich.
Tochter Tamara
kommt häufig zu Besuch.
Als ihr Vater arbeitslos wurde,
wohnte sie als Studentin
noch im Elternhaus.
Die Stimmung innerhalb der Familie
hat sich schon verändert.
Es gab Momente,
in denen wir angespannter waren.
Man machte sich vielleicht
mehr Gedanken.
Man fragte sich,
wie es dem anderen wirklich geht.
Was man vorher
vielleicht weniger machte,
weil man wusste,
dass immer etwas los ist.
Es hat sich schon viel verändert.
Wie ist das für mich ...
... mit dem Studium nebendran,
wenn ich noch nicht 100 % verdiene?
Kann ich zu Hause
genug Unterstützung leisten?
Wird meine Unterstützung
überhaupt angenommen?
Das ist ja für die Eltern
auch nicht immer einfach.
Man arbeitet das Leben lang
und plötzlich geht es darum,
auszusteuern.
Das war auch ein Schritt,
das im Freundeskreis ...
... anzusprechen.
Es gibt doch noch ein Stigma.
Es ist schon sehr negativ behaftet.
Wie ihr Bruder Matthias
ging sie zunächst davon aus,
dass der Vater
schnell wieder Arbeit findet.
Beide täuschten sich.
Du kannst es probieren.
Zwei Jahre
bekam Knuchel Arbeitslosengeld.
Ja, ist gut.
- Wunderbar.
Dann wurde er ausgesteuert.
Er lebt heute ohne Einkommen
und bezieht keine Sozialhilfe,
sonst müsste er das Haus verkaufen.
Matthias kann als Medizinstudent
nichts beisteuern.
Aber die Familie hält zusammen.
- Sie müssen gar nicht viel machen.
Wenn sie nur hier sind
und man einen gewissen Kontakt hat,
gibt das schon ein gutes Gefühl.
Ich denke, wenn man alleine ist ...
... hat man es schwieriger.
Langzeitarbeitslosigkeit - eine
enorme Belastung für die Betroffenen
und ihre Angehörigen.
Heidi Knuchel hat ihre Stelle
von 60 auf 100 % aufgestockt,
um den Einkommensverlust
ihres Mannes aufzufangen.
Sie möchte sich in diesem Film
nicht äussern.
Ein grosser Tag für Andreas Knuchel.
Er hat es geschafft.
Von einem Tag auf den anderen
fand er eine neue Stelle.
Pensum: 40 %.
Es ist ein super Gefühl.
Auch der Job an sich
ist wahnsinnig spannend.
Anfangs habe ich
natürlich noch Einarbeitungszeit,
sodass ich weiss,
wie der Hase läuft.
Aber ich freue mich.
Knuchel
ist für eine Teamsitzung angereist.
Er arbeitet neu für SkillSonics,
ein Start-up-Unternehmen,
das die Schweizer Berufslehre
ins Ausland exportieren will.
(Mann) How can you engage?
Vielleicht könnten wir ja,
wenn wir ein Konzept haben,
das Gespräch
mit ein paar Gruppen suchen
und schauen, ob es so passt, wie wir
es konzeptionell aufgestellt haben.
Lesson plan
und solche Informationen.
Seine Aufgabe ist es, Partnerfirmen
im In- und Ausland zu finden,
die qualifiziertes Personal brauchen
und darum
in die Berufsschulen investieren.
Vielleicht gibt es an einem anderen
Ort einen anderen Partner.
Der neue Chef
schenkt Knuchel Vertrauen.
Ich sehe immer wieder
ältere Semester,
die eine ganz andere Flexibilität
haben.
Einer der grossen Vorteile,
den man hat:
Man ist im familiären Rahmen
in der Regel gesetzt.
Man hat ein gutes Fundament
und sucht nicht noch überall rum.
Man ist unter Umständen
eher fokussierter
und manchmal oder vielfach
sogar eher flexibler.
Wir haben das nicht ausgeschrieben,
auch, weil ich dachte, es sei
so schwierig, jemanden zu finden,
der in diese Konstellation
reinpasst.
Wir machen etwas, das wahrscheinlich
noch niemand so gemacht hat.
Es ist etwas Spezielles.
Und ...
Es ist gut, wenn jemand da ist,
der eine vertiefte Berufserfahrung
hat,
der sehr gute Erfahrung
aus der Wirtschaft hat.
Das findet man bei jemand Jüngerem
nicht einfach so.
* Ruhige Klänge *
Vom Job her ist es absolut top.
Ich bin zufrieden.
Es ist wirklich sehr spannend.
Es ist ein ganz neues Gebiet.
Der internationale Approach
ist nach wie vor da,
aber vom Arbeitsgebiet her
ist es etwas ganz anderes.
Das ist eigentlich super.
Andererseits ist natürlich ...
... das Gehalt, das Einkommen
gegenüber meines vorherigen Jobs
massiv tiefer.
Würde man meinen Job
auf 100 % hochrechnen,
sind es gut 40 % davon.
Das hat ja auch mittelbar und
unmittelbar einen Einfluss darauf,
was man Ende Monat
zur Verfügung hat,
und es leidet auch
die Pensionskasse darunter.
Die Löcher in der Vorsorge
sind nicht mehr zu stopfen.
Er wird auch nach der Pensionierung
noch an den Folgen der Arbeits-
losigkeit leiden - lebenslänglich.
* Nachdenkliche Klänge *
Das war vor drei Jahren.
Heute heisst es: zurück auf Feld 1.
Andreas Knuchel
ist wieder arbeitslos.
Die Stelle bei SkillSonics
hat er nach eineinhalb Jahren
wieder verloren.
Ein Strategiewechsel
in der Akquisition war der Grund.
Fast nahtlos fand er als freier
Mitarbeiter eine Anschlusslösung,
um kurz darauf wegen Corona
wieder auf der Strasse zu stehen.
Einerseits merkt man schnell,
dass man irgendwie
nicht mehr so dazugehört.
Es ruft häufig niemand mehr an.
Dann wollen die Leute
im Bekanntenkreis,
wenn man sich trifft,
über die Arbeit sprechen.
Dort ist man auch nicht mehr dabei.
Die schlimmsten Momente
sind genau die,
wenn über die Arbeit,
den Arbeitgeber usw. gejammert wird.
Dann muss ich sagen:
"Freunde, überlegt mal ...
... wie es
auf der anderen Seite aussieht."
"Es gibt viele, die das
gerne in Kauf nehmen würden."
Knuchel
lebt nach wie vor ohne Einkommen.
Wegen seiner Selbstständigkeit
hat er kein Recht
auf Arbeitslosenentschädigung.
Bewerben Sie sich überhaupt noch?
Ich interessiere mich für Stellen,
die ausgeschrieben sind.
Aber ich bewerbe mich in dem Sinne,
dass ich ein Bewerbungsschreiben
auf die Reise schicke.
Wir wissen ja mittlerweile,
dass es dort auch Softwares gibt,
die eine Vorselektion machen.
Und aus dem Grund werden oft die
etwas erfahreneren Kandidaten ...
... auf den falschen Stapel
geschoben.
Was für einen Stellenwert
hat Arbeit für Sie,
seit Sie keine mehr haben?
Ich denke, dass sie einen
höheren Stellenwert erhalten hat,
als sie das vorher hatte,
als ich in der Arbeitswelt drin war.
Das ist durchaus so.
In drei Jahren
wird Andreas Knuchel pensioniert.
Seinen Ruhestand
hat er sich anders vorgestellt.
Die finanziellen Reserven
sind aufgebraucht.
Glücklich werden kann man so nicht.
Ich kann ohne Arbeit
auch nicht zufrieden werden.
Was ein Mensch immer braucht,
ist eine gewisse Wertschätzung.
Die sollte man auf diese Art
und Weise bis zur Pension -
wann immer die ist - erleben können.
* Nachdenkliche Klänge *
Ich sitze im Think Tank W.I.R.E.,
mit dessen Leiter Stephan Sigrist.
Ihr beschäftigt euch genau
mit solchen Zukunftsfragen.
Wohin geht die Gesellschaft?
Wie entwickelt sich die Arbeit?
Wir gehen zurück zu Andreas Knuchel.
Wir diskutieren immer
über Rentenerhöhungen.
Wir sind uns bewusst, dass wir alle
eher länger arbeiten werden.
Andererseits gibt es
immer mehr Leute, die merken,
dass ab Ende 50
Ende der Fahnenstange ist.
Niemand stellt sie mehr ein.
Wie geht das auf?
Das sind verschiedene Kräfte.
Einerseits leben wir zum Glück
alle viel länger.
Da ist es naheliegend,
dass wir auch länger arbeiten.
Andererseits
gibt es eben die Tendenz.
Das hat aber weniger damit zu tun,
dass ältere Leute
nicht einstellbar sind,
sondern mehr
mit der Sozialversicherung.
Es gibt höhere Beiträge.
Wir haben eine Kultur aufgebaut,
in der man glaubt,
dass möglichst viele Stunden und
möglichst leistungsfähig besser ist.
Es gibt viele Studien, die zeigen,
dass ältere Mitarbeiter
einen sehr grossen Beitrag
leisten könnten und würden.
Aber dann müsste man über
die Arbeitsmodalitäten nachdenken.
Z.B. muss der Lohn
nicht immer weiter nach oben gehen,
sondern könnte einen Peak haben
und irgendwann geht er nach unten.
Das macht es attraktiver,
ältere Leute einzustellen.
Müssen wir unsere Einstellung
zur Arbeit verändern?
Müssen wir unsere Wertschätzung
an einem anderen Ort suchen?
Jein. Arbeit ist ein elementarer
Bestandteil unseres Alltags
und unserer Welt.
Das war in der Vergangenheit so
und wird in der Zukunft so sein.
Grundsätzlich glaube ich,
spricht vieles dafür,
dass wir nicht alle
arbeitslos sein werden
und nicht 60 % der Leute
ihre Jobs verlieren.
Es wird eher das passieren,
was man bei anderen industriellen
Revolutionen auch gesehen hat:
dass neue Jobs dazukommen.
Aber alle Übergänge
sind mit sog. Hiccups verbunden,
d.h., es wird Leute geben, die
vorübergehend ihre Arbeit verlieren,
bis sich das eingestellt hat.
D.h. auch, dass das Ausrichten
auf eine Arbeit nicht ausreicht,
sondern, dass es
mehrere Standbeine braucht.
Ich habe gelesen, dass Babys,
die heute geboren werden,
Berufe erlernen werden,
die es heute noch gar nicht gibt.
Trotzdem gibt es Dinge,
die ein fester Wert sind,
z.B. Handwerker.
- Absolut.
Wir leben nach wie vor
in einer realen, haptischen Welt.
Wir müssen essen,
wir werden krank ...
Es ist eine grosse Illusion,
wenn man glaubt,
dass die Digitalisierung bedeutet,
dass das Haptische
und die reale Welt wegfallen.
Wenn wir von der Schweiz sprechen,
ist das duale Bildungssystem
mit den Lehren und den Handwerken
extrem wichtig -
und vielleicht
für die Zukunft noch wichtiger,
weil wir
beide Seiten zusammenbringen.
Ein zentraler Innovationsfaktor
für ein Land wie die Schweiz
ist nicht, mit dem Silicon Valley
oder mit den Chinesen
in den Wettbewerb zu treten.
Wir sind nicht gross genug.
Wir sind kompetent in der Wissen-
schaft, der Mechanik und Elektronik,
aber wir haben auch das Handwerk.
Leandra Wolfisberg.
Ihr Job hat Zukunft.
Die 16-Jährige wird Maurerin.
Anina Mutter.
Ihre Heimat ist die digitale Welt.
Freunde ...
... hoher Besuch.
Das SRF ist bei uns.
Ich bin immer auf normal.
Also nichts verschönert oder so.
D.h., wenn man mich
auf der Strasse antrifft,
sieht man genau das,
was man auch online sieht.
Dann schreibe ich
noch einen Text dazu.
Dann geht das online.
Yes, beautiful.
Gut, bleib dort stehen.
Ja.
Anina Mutter
ist Nachhaltigkeitsbloggerin.
Die Outfits ihrer Modeshootings
beispielsweise sind fair produziert
oder neu genäht aus Second-Hand-Mode.
* Beschwingte Klänge *
Ich erwische mich manchmal dabei,
dass ich denke:
"Wow, ich verdiene Geld mit dem,
was ich mache."
Wenn man so Momente hat, kann man es
als Traumjob beschreiben.
Glücksmomente bei der Arbeit
mit Fotografin Nicole Roetheli.
* Beschwingte Klänge *
Die Welt
der 16-jährigen Leandra Wolfisberg
ist aktuell
eine Grossbaustelle in Baar.
Es ist manchmal schon streng,
wenn es halt mega kalt
oder extrem heiss oder windig ist.
Aber ich würde sagen,
dass man sich daran gewöhnt.
Es gibt in jedem Job Dinge,
die man nicht so gerne macht.
Aber im Grossen und Ganzen
mache ich alles gern.
Ein Traumjob?
Ja.
* Sie lacht. *
Ich hatte Glück,
ihn direkt zu finden.
Ihr Handwerk hat auch in Zukunft
goldenen Boden,
denn sie und ihre Kollegen
werden in absehbarer Zukunft
nicht durch Roboter ersetzt,
sagt
der Schweizerische Baumeisterverband.
In ihrer virtuellen Welt
wachse das Bedürfnis,
mit den Händen
in der Erde zu buddeln,
sagt Nachhaltigkeitsbloggerin
Anina Mutter.
Top.
Hat man da
nicht immer den Hintergedanken,
wenn man einen Garten hat oder
einfach in der Freizeit etwas macht,
ob man vielleicht
eine Story daraus machen soll?
Ich glaube,
das ist schon Teil meines ...
... Blogger-Dasein,
dass ich meinen Lifestyle teile.
Aber mittlerweile ist es eher:
"Das ist ein schöner Moment.
Ich geniesse ihn für mich."
Bei mir hat sich das etwas gedreht.
Ich finde, dass ich nicht jeden
einzelnen Moment einfangen muss
und immer und überhaupt.
Es ist dann eher ...
... schön,
das mal offline zu geniessen.
Anina Mutter ist Schauspielerin
und hat einen Bachelor
in Designmanagement.
Dann schreibe ich "harvest"
oder "today's harvest".
Zack.
Voilà.
Und dann geht das online.
Als ich klein war,
wollte ich Tierärztin werden.
Oder Coiffeuse.
Das mit dem Bau
hat sich erst später entwickelt,
so als ich zwölf, 13 war.
Die meisten Leute sind erstaunt,
wenn sie mich zum ersten Mal sehen.
Aber wenn sie mich kennenlernen,
merken sie,
dass es vom Charakter her
gut zu mir passt
und dass ich das gerne mache.
Welchen Charakter
hat denn jemand auf dem Bau?
Wir nehmen die Dinge einfach nicht
so ernst wie vielleicht andere.
Wir sind etwas härter im Nehmen,
würde ich sagen.
Wir sind uns einiges gewohnt -
vom Wetter
und körperlichen Arbeiten her.
Man merkt einfach,
dass wir Teamplayer sind.
Wir müssen
mit den Leuten zusammenarbeiten.
Gut?
- Gut!
So.
Und das KV, ins Büro -
wäre das nichts gewesen?
Nein, sicher nicht.
Warum nicht?- Weil mir das
einfach zu langweilig ist.
Ich habe hier mein Profil und ...
- Wie viele Follower hast du?
16'400.
Sind das viele?
Im internationalen ...
Nein, sogar im allgemeinen Vergleich
sind das nicht viele.
Aber es kommt mittlerweile ...
... nicht mehr so stark auf die
Menge an, sondern auf die Qualität.
Ein grosser Teil interessiert sich
tatsächlich für Nachhaltigkeit.
Für einen Brand ist es interessant,
mit mir zu arbeiten,
weil er weiss:
"Wenn ich mit Anina arbeite,
habe ich ziemlich sicher
ein Zielpublikum,
das ähnliche Werte hat wie sie."
Dann kann man ein Produkt
natürlich interessant platzieren.
Das ist z.B.
eine Zusammenarbeit mit der SBB.
Da warte ich mit Pax auf den Zug.
Es ist doch ein Glücksgewinn,
wenn Sie sich selber in
diesen schönen Kleidern usw. sehen.
Ja, ich glaube, ich habe das Ganze
einfach schon durchschaut.
Ich muss leider mitteilen,
dass Fame und Sichtbarkeit
kein Garant für Glück sind.
Wir haben ja genügend Beispiele
von sehr berühmten Menschen,
die zeigen, dass das
nicht der Schlüssel zum Glück ist.
* Beschwingte Klänge *
Die ist nicht ganz gerade.
Aber fast.
* Beschwingte Klänge *
Ich gehe zwei- bis dreimal pro Woche
in den Stall.
Wir haben noch Pferde.
Und ich habe noch einen Hund.
Ich gehe auch noch dreimal pro Woche
ins Kickboxen.
Und ein Gym-Abo habe ich auch noch.
Also ...
... die Woche
ist jeweils relativ voll,
sagen wir es so.
Wie müsste ein Mann sein,
der zu dir passt?
Ja, lustig. Einfach ein Lustiger,
der arbeiten kann.
Ich weiss es nicht.
- Ein Influencer käme nicht infrage?
Nein, das funktioniert nicht.
Zu viele Frauen, die da folgen.
Das wäre nicht so meins,
wenn er immer das Handy rausnehmen
und zeigen muss,
was er alles gemacht hat
und wo er überall war.
Dass er dort das und das
getestet hat
und dort das gratis erhalten hat,
weil er etwas gesagt hat.
Ich mache
und kommuniziere die Dinge,
weil das tatsächlich
meine Werte sind.
Ich lebe das und lebe das
auch abseits der Kamera.
Grundsätzlich ist es so, dass alles,
was Planet, Mensch und Tier
nicht respektiert
für mich nicht infrage kommt.
Ich möchte mich nicht ...
... mit etwas kleiden, etwas essen
usw., das Schaden anrichtet.
Und ich will das natürlich
erst recht nicht bewerben.
Das ist mal eine andere Farbe.
Die Arbeit, die ich mache,
ist meine Art und Weise,
zu versuchen,
etwas besser zu machen.
Ich leiste so meinen Beitrag dazu,
dass der Planet vielleicht
nicht noch mehr kaputtgeht.
Ich glaube, ich brauche das.
Wenn ich noch versuchen kann,
jemanden zu einem positiven
Lebenswandel zu inspirieren,
gibt mir das einen gewissen Sinn.
Zucker? Milch?
- Gerne.
Du bist gut.
Eh, eine neue Uhr.
- Schon lange.
Allein unter lauter Männern -
Arbeitsalltag für die 16-jährige
Leandra Wolfisberg.
Ich habe einen pinken Becher.
Ich kenne halt nichts anderes.
Aber sie sind alle
wie kleine Brüder.
Das kann man so sagen.
- Kleine Brüder?- Ja.
Aber du bist doch die Jüngste.
Ja, aber die machen
noch mehr Mist als ich.
Wurde anfangs immer blöd geschaut:
"Da kommt eine Frau. Was macht die?"
Nein. Sie waren eigentlich offen.
Sie reagierten,
als würde ein Mann kommen.
Normal: "Wer bist du?
Was machst du?"
Dann wird man akzeptiert.
Man lernt sich ja kennen.
Muss Arbeit
überhaupt glücklich machen?
Ja, ich finde schon.
Arbeit
nimmt so einen grossen Teil ...
... in meinem Leben ein.
Es macht mich zu unglücklich,
wenn sie mich nicht glücklich macht.
Ich brauche etwas,
das mich zumindest minimal erfüllt,
damit ich meine Zeit
auch gerne darin investiere.
Das kann ja
mega unterschiedlich sein.
Ich kann mir auch gut vorstellen,
dass es mal etwas anderes sein wird.
Ich kann mich für vieles begeistern.
Dies ist es einfach im Moment.
Auf dem Bau als Maurerin arbeiten?
Wieso nicht? Ich bin
eine sehr körper... körper...
... eine körperliche Person.
Ich bin mit Bewegung aufgewachsen.
Ich fing mit fünf Jahren an
ins Kunstturnen zu gehen.
Ich arbeite gerne hart.
Ich machte mal ein Praktikum
auf einem Bio-Bauernhof.
Alles, was haptisch ist ...
... und auch sehr ... so ...
Was halt nicht virtuell ist.
Man baut etwas,
man hat etwas in der Hand und so.
Das kann ich mir
sehr gut vorstellen.
Ich sehe noch nichts, weisst du.
23,6.
Ich finde es wichtig,
dass Arbeit glücklich macht.
Wenn man mit einem guten Gefühl
zur Arbeit gehen kann
und sich irgendwie
auch darauf freut,
kommt das sicher immer besser.
Ich denke auch,
dass Erfolg darauf basiert,
dass man zufrieden damit ist,
was man macht.
Gehst du zufrieden in den Feierabend?
Ich freue mich auf morgen.
Wenn ich wieder arbeiten kann.
Ja.
Nein, ich bin zufrieden.
Es ist grossartig, wenn man das
über seine Arbeit sagen kann.
Aber wenn der Job
noch nicht erfunden wurde,
der so richtig,
richtig glücklich macht:
Wie müsste der Job aussehen?
Wir haben die Passantinnen
und Passanten gefragt.
Welchen Job müsste man für Sie
noch erfinden?- Ferien.
Eine Kombination aus Lehrerin
und Cupcake-Verkäuferin.
Etwas, bei dem man mit Leuten zu tun
und seine Ruhe hat.
Etwas drin und etwas draussen.
Irgendetwas mit Schlafen.
- Nur Mami sein dürfen.
Ein Café, in dem man basteln kann.
Eine grosse Farm aufmachen
mit einem Bed and Breakfast -
etwas in die Richtung.
Wo man etwas flexibel sein und
in die Ferien kann, wann man will
und sich
eine längere Auszeit nehmen kann.
Rundum glücklich wäre ich sicher,
wenn ich nie arbeiten müsste.
Mein Traumjob
wäre zwei Tage zu arbeiten ...
... und fünf Tage zu ruhen.
Fünf Tage frei
und nur zwei Tage arbeiten.
Das ist eine Idealvorstellung.
Stephan Sigrist, ist das realistisch?
Arbeiten wir in Zukunft eher weniger?
Wenn man den generellen Meinungen
der Zukunftsforscher
und Technologiegläubigen glaubt,
durchaus.
Dann nehmen uns die Roboter
und Maschinen alles ab
und wir sind im Park
und lesen und so.
Aber ich glaube,
das ist nicht ganz realistisch
und unter Umständen
auch gar nicht so wünschenswert,
wie es klingt.
- Das wollte ich gerade sagen.
Würde Sie das glücklich machen, wenn
Sie viel weniger arbeiten würden?
Man muss vielleicht
einen Schritt zurück machen
und dazu zurückkommen,
was quasi mit dem Glück zu tun hat.
Das hat mit Selbstbestimmung
und Selbstwirksamkeit zu tun -
dass man etwas machen kann.
Ich kann mir andere Tätigkeiten
vorstellen, die ich gerne mache.
Aber das Ganze hat auch etwas
mit Produktivität zu tun -
dass man etwas Neues erschafft.
Man will ja etwas leisten.
- Und mit Leistung.
Wir wollen etwas Neues kreieren.
Die Vorstellung davon,
den ganzen Tag am Strand zu liegen
und zu warten, dass etwas passiert,
macht nicht glücklich.
Man sieht es bei Kindern:
Wenn sie spielen,
simulieren sie eine Tätigkeit,
die eine Aufgabe ist.
Es liegt tief
in der Natur des Menschen,
dass man eine Aufgabe hat
und diese auch sucht.
Ob das bezahlte Arbeit
oder eine andere Tätigkeit ist,
darüber kann man diskutieren.
Aber eine Aufgabe
oder eine Arbeit an sich
ist sicher
ein sehr zentrales Element
für die Zufriedenheit und das Glück.
- Ja.
Und für das,
was wir erreichen möchten.
Es ist viel in Bewegung.
Vielen Dank, Stephan Sigrist.
Bei Ihnen zu Hause drehen sich
jetzt sicher ein paar Rädchen.
Macht Arbeit glücklich?
Muss sie überhaupt glücklich machen?
Oder müssen wir unser Glück
an einem anderen Ort suchen?
Wenn Sie morgen in die neue
Arbeitswoche starten, hoffe ich,
dass Sie einen Job machen können,
der Sie zumindest zufrieden macht,
wenn er Sie nicht glücklich macht.
Vielen Dank fürs Interesse
und einen schönen Abend.
Ich habe ihm anfangs gesagt,
dass er arbeiten
und ein Dogfluencer werden muss.
* Rülpser *
- Oh!- Rülpsen wie ein Weltmeister.
Ich habe eigentlich Höhenangst.
Ich weiss nicht,
ob ich die Leiter hochkomme.
Wenn ich abends bereichert
bzw. etwas schlauer ins Bett gehe,
als ich morgens aufgestanden bin,
war das für mich
eigentlich ein erfüllter Tag.
Arbeit macht ...
... vielleicht glücklich,
aber sicher zufrieden.
Komm!
SWISS TXT / Access Services
puretype gmbh - 2021